you've tweeted that quote origin of Life
research is a scam
so if this is Shakespeare can we analyze
this word why why is the origin of Life
research a scam aren't you kind of doing
origin of Life research
um okay it was tongue and Shake but yeah
I think and I meant it as
tongue-in-cheek
um I am I'm not doing or I'm not doing
the origin of Life research I'm trying
to make artificial life and I also want
to to bound the likelihood of me of the
origin of life on Earth but more
importantly to find origin of life
elsewhere but let me directly address
the Tweet there are many many good
chemists out there doing origin of Life
research but I want to nudge them and I
think they're brilliant like like
there's no there's there's no question
the chemistry they are doing their
motivation is great
so what I meant by that tweet is saying
that maybe they're making assumptions
about saying if only
I could make this particular type of
molecule say this RNA molecule or this
uh phosphodiester or this other molecule
it's going to somehow unlock the origin
of life
and I think that origin of life has been
looking at this for a very long time and
whilst I I think it's brilliant to work
out how you can get to those molecules I
think that chemistry and chemists doing
origin of Life Could
be nudged into doing something even more
profound and and so the argument I'm
making it's a bit like right now
let's say I don't know the first Tesla
that makes its way to
I don't know into a new country in the
world let's say I let's say there's
country X that has never had a Tesla
before and they get the Tesla Russia and
they take the test and what they do is
they take the tester apart and say we
want to find the origin of of cars in
the universe and say okay how did this
form and how did this fall and they just
randomly keep making till they make the
door they make the wheel they make the
steering column and all this stuff and
and they say oh that's the route that's
the way that's the way cars emerged on
Earth but actually we know that there's
a causal chain of cars going right back
to Henry Ford and the horse and carriage
and before that maybe you know
um where people were using wheels and
and I think that obsession with the
identities that we see in biology right
now are giving us a false sense of
security but what we're looking for and
I think the origin of Life chemistry
is in danger of of not making the
progress that it deserves because the
chemists are doing this as the field is
exploding right now there's amazing
people out there young and old doing
this and there's deservedly so more
money going in you know I used to
complain there's more money being spent
searching for the Higgs boson that we
know exists in the origin of life you
know why is that the origin we
understand the origin of life we're
going to actually work on what life is
and we're going to be out of bound the
likelihood of finding life elsewhere in
the universe and most important for us
we are going to know or have a good idea
what the future of humanity looks like
you know we need to understand that
although we're precious we're not the
only life forms in the universe or
that's my very strong impression I have
no data for that it's just right now I
believe and I want to turn that belief
into a more than a belief by by
experimentation but I coming back to the
scam the scam is if we just make this
RNA we've we've got this you know this
uh this fluke event we know how that's
simple let's make this phosphodiester or
let's make ATP or ADP we've got that
part nailed let's now make this other
molecule another molecule and how many
molecules are going to be enough and
then the reason I say this is when you
go back to Craig Venter when he invented
his life form cindia
this micro this this minimal plasmid
it's a it's a myoplasma something I
don't know the name of it but he made
this wonderful
um cell and said I've I've invented life
not quite he facsimiled the genome from
this entity and made it in the lab or
the DNA but he didn't make the cell he
had to take an existing cell that has a
causal chain going all the way back to
Luca and he showed when he took out the
gene the the genes and put in his genes
synthesized the cell could boot up but
it's remarkable that he could not make
herself from scratch and even now today
synthetic biologists cannot make a cell
from scratch because there's some
contingent information embodied outside
the genome in the cell and that is just
incredible so there's lots of layers to
the scam